madame Aubry disait historiquement quand
il y a du flou il y a un loup
et donc la Garou
comment bon bref vous m'avez compris
monsieur le ministre vous nous indiquez
que le précédent président de la
République aurait fixé une règle je
m'excuse les édits du président de la
République ne sont pas des lois ce sont
peut-être des us et coutumes mais ça n'a
pas une valeur législative qui s'impose
heureusement nous ne sommes plus un
royauté bon deuxièmement vous vous nous
dites qu'il est possible de consulter
les notes de synthèse mais pourquoi les
cacher
vous nous avez fait d'ailleurs vous
chers collègues de LR des grandes
déclarations pour nous expliquer les
référendum c'était pas bien parce qu'il
fallait consolider la démocratie
parlementaire et ben pour que le
Parlement délibert il doit être
réellement éclairé par le gouvernement
or le gouvernement lui cache
manifestement des éléments qui ont été
mis à sur la table par le Conseil d'État
et si nous les cache ce n'est pas par
hasard c'est que a priori il y aurait un
certain nombre d'articles prévus dans
cette loi qui ne sont pas conformes à
notre Constitution et ces articles même
à supposer qu'il soit pas le cœur de
cible à savoir l'allongement de la
retraite avec un départ à 64 ans
constitue le gros de votre argumentaire
pour nous dire c'est pas catastrophique
on a mis des rustines puisque par
exemple l'indice seniors etc etc vous
trompez donc par votre manque
d'information la délibération de notre
assemblée et par la même les Français